مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياضة أذي ابرز وعناوينها
استنفار في بريطانيا ثلاثه حوادث امنيه
مترابطه في نوتينغام والعثور على ثلاثه
قتله واعتقال شخص
زخم سياسي واقتصادي تشهد السعوديه الشهر
الخلي والاعلان عن طريق حرير جديده مع
الصين
حجاج السوداني يبداون التوافد في
بورتسودان 747 حاجا سيتم تفويجهم الى جده
في الرابعه
استراتيجيات النقل في السعوديه تكمل عامها
الثاني ناقل جديد وخصخصه مستمره للمطارات
ولجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده تعتمد
العاشره من فبراير يوما عالميا للنمر
العربي
اعلنت شرطه البريطانيه القاء القبض على
منفذ جريمه القتل في مدينه نوتينغهام وهو
شاب في الحاديه من العمر الشرطه قالت ان
قوتها تتعامل مع ثلاث عمليات امنيه
متزامنه في انحاء متفرقه ومتباعده
بنوتينغا اسفرت حتى الان عن وقوع ثلاثه
قتله وثلاثه جرحى صدمتهم شاحنه صغيره
وقالت قائده الشرطه ان التحقيقات الاوليه
تشير الى ان الحوادث كلها مرتبطه مع بعضها
هذا وقال رئيس الوزراء البريطاني لكنه على
اطلاع دائم بالتطورات الاخيره وان
التحقيقات بشان الحوادث التي اسفرت عن
سقوط ضحايا مستمره وطالب سونيك باعطاء
الشرطه الوقت الكافيه للقيام بعملهم وكشفي
ملابسات الحوادث مؤكدا وقوفه مع عائلات
الضحايا كما اشاد بدوري الشرطه وخدمات
الطوارئ على استجابتهم السريعه للحوادث
التي وصفها بالصادمه
تنضم الينا مديره مكتبه العرب مكتب
العربيه في لندن ريما مكتب يعني ريما ما
هو جديد التطورات
في اخر المستجدات ان الشرطه شرطه
او حتى الشرطه البريطانيه تنفذ عمليات
مداهمه
قربى المواقع احد المواقع او الشوارع حيث
وجد شخصان مقتولان بسبب عمليات امنيه
متزامنه بدات الساعه الرابعه فجرا في شارع
الكستون في نوتنغها في نوتينغهام
نوتنهام تبعد قرابه ساعتين بالقطار على
الاقل من لندن اذا العمليه بدات الساعه
الرابعه شهود عيان يقولون انهما راوا شخصا
يرتدي الثياب السوداء وهو داكن البشره
اسود ويضع قبعه على راسه قام بطعم شاب او
صبي وامراه وارداهما عده طعنات وذهب من
موقع الجريمه بالكثير من الهدوء ومن دون
اي خوف وارتياب وبعد ذلك قرابه الخامسه
والنصف صباحا بتوقيت المحلي ايضا استدعيت
الشرطه لعمليه دهم حصلت عبر فان
ونقل ثلاثه اشخاص الى المستشفى للمعالجه
وفي شارع مبدله شارع ثالث بمحيط مدينه
نوتنهام وجد شخص مقتولا الشرطه تعتبر ان
العمليات الثلاث مترابطه وهناك عمليه
تحقيق تجري مع شخص تم اعتقاله عمره 31
عاما
الى اين تتجه هذه العمليه في
تاويلاتها حسب يعني ما يتم تداوله في بريط
شرطه مكافحه الارهاب متواجده على الارض
كبار الاجهزه الامنيه متواجده العمليه
مستمره منذ الرابعه فجرا اصبحت الساعه
الثانيه بعد الظهر بالتوقيت المحلي عمليه
امنيه منذ ساعات الكثير من التحقيقات عبر
الكاميرات كاميرات المراقبه في الشوارع
اجهزه التليفون وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
الكمبيوترز وايضا مداهمات تجري الان الطوق
الامني لازال حول مدينه نوتينغهام يعني
مساحه
700 كم مربع نتحدث عن ست شوارع على الاقل
حولها طوق امني لم تصرح الشرطه البريطانيه
اذا ما كان الحادث ارهابي ام لا ولكن عاده
ما تاخذ الشرطه وقتها لاعلان عن هكذا
حوادث سواء كانت ارهابيه ام لا لا شك ان
التحقيقات مستمره ومسرح الجريمه يعتبر
اكتف او ناشط مما يعني انه يتخ وفون من
عمليات ارهابيه ثانيه او حتى اعتداءات
ثانيه ومن المرات القليله التي نرى الشرطه
مسلحه بالكامل ومقنعه متواجده على مسرح
الجريمه شكرا جزيلا لك رمى مكتب مديره
مكتب العربيه في لندن
زخم كبير عاشته وتعيشه السعوديه الشهر
الحالي سياسيا واقتصاديا وحتى رياضيا
الزميله شهد المتروك تعرفنا على ابرز
الاحداث التي عاشتها السعوديه منذ مطلع
يونيو
يونيو ساخن تعيشه السعوديه على جميع
الاصعده زخم كبير سياسي واقتصادي يوطد
مكانه الرياض وريادتها في الاقليمي
والعالم نبدا من لقاء ولي العهد السعودي
الامير محمد بن سلمان بوزير الخارجيه
الامريكي في جده تناول اللقاء قضايا
المنطقه وعلى راسها مكافحه الارهاب وسبل
تحقيق السلام في اليمن فضلا عن تعميق
التعاون الاقتصادي والعلمي بين الرياض
وواشنطن وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه قال
اثناء مغادرته السعوديه انه سعيد بما وصفه
بالسبل الجديده للتعاون مع شركاء
السعوديين مؤكدا العمل مع الرياض للتصدي
للتحديات العالميه
من الزخم السياسي نتحول الى قرار اقتصادي
لا يقل اهميه وهو خفض الانتاج في اوبك بلس
صاحبته ردود فعل واسعه بين مؤيد ومعارض
لسياسه السعوديه التي تقود الحلف احدث
ردود الفعل جاءت قبل ايام من الكرملين حيث
قال المتحدث باسم الرئاسه الروسيه
ان السعوديه دوله مسؤوله ولاعب مهم في
اسواق الطاقه وليست بحاجه لاي وصايه او
مواعظ على حد تعبيره دعونا نذكر او نذكر
بتصريحات وزير الطاقه السعودي الامير عبد
العزيز بن سلمان الذي اكد ان السعوديه ليس
لديها عقده المضاربين في اسواق النفط
لا احنا ما عندنا عقده مضاربين يمكن في
منحاول يدفع بهذا كثير لكن
هي زي اللي مارسناها في عام 21
اعتقد انه كل اجراءاتنا الاخيره حتى في
شهر ابريل تخفيض اللي سوت الدول المشاركه
معنا
لمنفرده سويتك كقرار منفرد لكل دوله هو
قرار تحوطي في السادسه من يونيو شهدت
العاصمه السعوديه اعاده فتح السفاره
الايرانيه في خطوه ضمن اتفاقي بكين الشهير
وكانت الخارجيه الايرانيه قد عينت علي رضا
عنايتي سفيرا جديدا لدى السعوديه ويشغل
عنايه حاليا منصب نائب وزير الخارجيه
بعدما كان سفيرا في الكويت
ذاته يونيو لا تنتهي حيث استضافت السعوديه
مؤتمر الرجال الاعمال العرب والصينيين
نتجت عنه اتفاقيات ضخمه بقيمه اجماليه
بلغت عشره مليارات دولار شملت ثلاثين صفقه
طريقه حرير عصريه جديده تربط الصين
بالعالم العربي كشف عنها وزير الاستثمار
السعودي المهندس خالد الفالح في تطور لافت
لاتساع العلاقات مع بكين
من اليوم ومن خلال هذا المؤتمر على اطلاق
طريق حرير عصريه جديده يكون محركها رؤيتنا
للتعاون والتشارك ووقود انطلاقتها هم
شبابنا وكذلك ابتكاراتنا لنحقق مصالحنا
ومصالح شركائنا في كل انحاء العالم
والخبير المتخصص في العلوم السياسيه
والعلاقات الدوليه الدكتور هشام الغني
دكتور هشام حياك الله معك في نشره الرابعه
مازال الحديث ايضا في وسائل الاعلام
الامريكيه حول زيارات المسؤولين
الامريكيين اخرها زياره وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي بلنكن هذا ثاني مسؤول امريكي
بارز يزور السعوديه خلال اقل من شهر بعد
زياره مستشار العام القومي للبيت الابيض
الجاك
الدلالات والنتائج اليوم لهذه الزياره الى
اي مدى حققت نتائجها
يعني بشكل عام يعني لاحظنا هناك اختلاف
حتى في الكونغرس الامريكي يعني حول مقاربه
العلاقه مع السعوديه يعني هناك اسف جمهوري
على سياسه البيت الابيض تجاه الرياض طبعا
داخل فيه العامري داخل الامريكي والحسبه
الداخليه الامريكيه مع ايضا خطاب ديمقراطي
هش ومتقلب وضبابي تجاه المملكه لكن اسمح
لي بهذه العباره استاذ خالد يعني انا محلل
في نهايه الامر
انا اعتقد ان اداره بايدن يعني عن جهل
وغرور كبير وعمد ايضا قد قوضت العلاقه مع
المملكه في بدايتها يعني نذكر انها مكرره
عده مرات انهم سيراجعون العلاقات الثنائيه
وهذه يعني كان في سياسه التفافيه اتضح
خطاها لاحقا اعتقد يعني هم ارادوا تراجع
عنها بطرق ملتويه كثيره لم تفلح هذه
الاساليب
حتى الان في رب راب الصدى يعني نتذكر
زياره بايدن المملكه وما تراها يعني في
ذلك الوقت لكن يعني شخصيا حتى لا احسب
متشائما طوال الوقت ارى ان هذه الزياره
يعني نوعيه مختلفه يعني زياره بنك الاخيره
هذه ربما تكون انعطاف ايجابيه بشكل علاقات
يعني في الفتره التي سبقت الزياره يعني
رغم الكلام تقول ماسي العلاقات يعني لم
تكن كما ينبغي لها ان تكون يعني اعتقد هذه
الزياره وربما تكون يعني تعيدها في الجهه
الصحيح وتصريح بلنك ايضا خالد يعني اعتقد
كان ايجابيا اعلن التصريحه يعني عن
استثمار بعمق في الشراكه المملكه لبناء
مستقبل اكثر اشراقا للشرق الاوسط على حد
تعبيره ترى هذه العباره انا اعتقد انها
ايضا معبئه ليست مجرد كلاش عابره يعني
خلفها ما خلفها
يعني هل يمكن القول بانه البيت الابيض كسب
الرهان من خلال هذه الزيارات الان في
ترميم العلاقات بين البلدين في اعاده
الدفء الى المسار ايضا بين الرياض واشنطن
ام مازال من المبكر الحديث عن ذلك
في ادراك متزايد بظني من قبل اداره
امريكيه باهميه وحجم دور المملكه خاصه هذه
السعوديه لمتجدده الاهميه يعني بالنسبه
لامريكا يبدو انه مصر لقناعه انه لا غنى
عن المملكه لتحقيق اهداف كبرى لامريكا في
العالم يعني الموضوع ليس ترى مرتبط كما
نسمع دائما باستقرار المنطقه ودور المملكه
في صخر منطقه لا الموضوع اكبر يعني اعتقد
ان امريكا هذه الاداره بالتحديد بدات يعني
يصل لها هذا الفهم من السعوديه تستطيعها
تحقيق اهداف لها حيويه وذات وزن لكنها
طبعا ايضا عمر عائد للمملكه يعني في نهايه
المطاف امراه السعوديه ان في هذا مصلحه
لها يعني
ستقوم به لكن ما تريد امريكا الشيء وما
يخدم السعوديه انا اعتقد بوجهه نظري انه
شيء اخر يعني المصالح ليست متطابقه بين
البلدين ممتاز تحدثت عن وثائق سريه قالت
فيها بان السعودي اللي هو بتغيير جذري في
العلاقه بين البلدين وهدد بالحاق الم
اقتصادي كبير بالولايات المتحده عندما
تنشر الولايات المتحده وصحف الامريكيه مثل
هذه الوثائق
وضعها ايضا في اطار التحليلات والقراءات
ايضا التي نشرت ايضا في في موضوع العلاقه
بين البلدين يعني ذلك او ليالي بان
الفجوه تتسع في العلاقه كثيرا بين البلدين
امر اصلاحها اصبح اصعب من من اي وقت
كما يرى
انا اعتقد الفجوه كانت موجوده يعني هذه
هذه تسريبات يعني التي ذكرتها او تقارير
الاخرى يعني هذه السناب شات يعني التقاطها
في وقتها يعني ويحقق انا بالنسبه لي يعني
لا يمكن معرفه حقيقه ان هذا كان هذه
تسريبات حقيقيه ام لا هذا معلومة لا
امتلكها لكنها ايضا بالتاكيد انها ربما
تعبر عن مزاج عام ترى العلاقه في وقت سابق
وتوقيت التسريب ايضا تراها خالد ليس بريال
يعني هذه صحيفه خصوصا لا موقف وتريد
استمرار التحريض يعني يعني غالبا يعني انا
اعتقد لا يجب اعطائي تسريبات اكثر من
حجمها الطبيعيه يعني هذه التسريبات تمثل
لقطه واحده زمنيه ولا يمكن انها تقدم
الصوره الكامله الصوره الكامله بينها في
العلاقات بين البلدين معقده جدا يعني لا
يمكن ان تحيط بها تسريب من هنا وتسريب من
هناك
مباشره بعد ساعات من هذه الزياره لوزير
الخارجيه الامريكي كان هناك اتصال جمع
اولي العهد السعودي بالرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوت
هل هناك يعني رساله مقصوده من الرياض من
هذا الاتصال بالربط بين التوقيت توقيت هذه
الزياره وهذا الاتصال
استراتيجي
يعني ايضا قراءه التجاد الماسيه شرقا
لتعزيز علاقتها مع الصين وروسيا يعني انه
على حساب علاقتها مع امريكا يردد كثيرا
يعني لكن فيما يبرره يعني مهمه الجمره لجت
علاقات الخارجيه يعني يقول يعني يقول على
مدى 80 عاما كاتب المملكه شريك مهم في
تعزيز الامن والمصالح وانه قد تاخر كثيرا
تعاون اداره بايدن مع المملكه يعني ترى
يعني التحركات السعوديه سواء هذا الاتصال
او غيره يعني هذا خيار منطقي ليس تحديا
وعنادا لدينا عالم ذاهب ان يكون متعدد
لقطاب صعب ان تكون العلاقه مع امريكا
حصريه وانا اعتقد ترى الفهم هذا واصل
الاداره الامريكيه واستوعبته اخيرا يعني
تعليق ايضا ترى خادم المتحدث بس وزاره
الخارجيه على المكالمه انا اظنه كان موجزا
ودبلوماسيا وهي لغه ترى مختلفه عن تصريحات
سابقه لمتحدثين رسميين في اداره بايدن
يعني هو كان تصريح يب من التفهم لمصالح
السعوديه وامرونا ايضا
للسعوديه سواء فيما يتعلق في اتفاق بلس او
غيره وهذا نظن مفيد لامريكا هي تحتاج شريك
موثوق مثل المملكه حتى في وساطات وحل
ازمات مختلفه تتعدى منطقتنا هذه المحدوده
وهذا اظنه مهم لامريكا لذلك نرى هذا
التفاهم وايضا مستوى الاحترام في هذه
التصريحات تختلف عن السابق نراجع تصريحاته
مقابل سنتين ما كان الوضع بهذا الشكل ابدا
احد اهم الملفات التي قيل بان جاك سوليفن
وكذلك الوزير الخارجيه الامريكي التي جاء
بها يعني الى الرياض موضوع تطبيع العلاقات
بين رياضه تل ابيب وهذا الامر ايضا كان قد
صرح بها وتحدث به
بلانك وزير الخارجيه الامريكي في خطابه في
المؤتمر الايبك
وقال بانه واشنطن ستستمر في الدفع بقوه
نحو يعني هذه الصفقه لكن الى اي مدى يمكن
واشنطن ان تبدل المزيد او هي مستعده لدفع
ثمن كبير لهذا الامر كما جاء يعني في بعض
الصحف الامريكيه من الرياض تطلب يعني
مفاعل نووي مدني تطلب كذلك فتح باب
الاسلحه ايضا بدون اغلاق
وكذلك ايضا اتفاق امني مشترك بين البلده
انا اعتقد في ثمه نقاط اساسيه يعني مهمه
في هذا الموضوع رغم تعقيده اولا تطبيع بين
السعوديه واسرائيل هذا يمثل هدف امريكي
قديم يعني ليس محصورا بهذه الاداره لكنه
هدف جديد ومهم جدا لدائره بايدن
الانتخابات انا اعتقد انها بسبب قرب
الانتخابات الرئيسيه اداره بايدن تريد
انجاز مثل هذا وهذا انجاز ليس سهله يعني
المملكه هي البوابه الفعليه للمنطقه
بالنسبه
لاسرائيل لو حدث تطبيع وايضا اثبات ان
امريكا ما زالت تلعب دورا فاعلا بالمنطقه
خصوصا يعني ما حدث مع الاتفاق السعودي
الايراني الذي تم برعايه صينيه يعني اي
طريقه نظرتها الاتفاق ويمثل الضربه
لامريكا ومصالح امريكا في المنطقه الان
يعني هل السعوديه مستعده للتطبيع هل
امريكا ايضا كما تفضلت مستعده للثمن يعني
ينبغي دفعه اعتقد فيه مغالطه يعني زياره
سبقتها زياره كما تفضلت جيك سلفن مستشار
الامن القومي وكلاهما معرض التطبيع
التطبيع ليس عرضا سعوديا هو عرض امريكي
لكن السعوديه ايضا من جاتا لا زالت مسره
على الالتزام بمبادره السلام العربيه لا
زالت مصره على ان يكون مقابل السلام دوله
فلسطينيه عاصمتها القدس الشرقيه
وايضا اداره امريكيه لديها مخاوف يعني هي
ترى ترى حتى استقلاليه السعوديه وايضا
تخشى من اسرائيل تشب على الطوق يعني وانا
اظن يعني حتى لو فشلت الاداره الامريكيه
في هدفها هذا تظل العلاقات السعوديه
امريكيه اعقد من سلوك اداره واحده حتى عده
ادارات لكن هل ستعطى هذه الاداره ما
طلبتها بدون تحقيق مصلحه سعوديه هذا
بالتاكيد لن يحدث لن يحدث شكرا جزيلا لك
دكتور هشام الغنام الاكاديمي الخبير
المتخصص في العلاقات او في العلوم
السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه شكرا جزيلا
ايضا بعد قليل
وزير الحج والعمره السعوديه واكد ان خدمه
الضيوف الرحمن منهج تاريخي للسعوديه
اهلا بكم من جديد افاد مراسل العربيه في
الخرطوم بانها 747 مواطنا سودانيا سيتم
تفويجهم لاداء مناسك الحج وبحسب امين
امانه الحج والعمره في ولايه نهر النيل
عبد الرؤوف حسن فقد تم الانتهاء من
ترتيبات الحج واستلام جوازات الحجاج
واستيفاء الجوازات الصحيه اضاف امين بان
ولايه نهر النيل استقبلت حتى الان
847 من حجاج ولايه الخرطوم بعد تعسر
الاوضاع الامنيه في السودان
[موسيقى]
وقد استقبل الامين العام لمنظمه التعاون
الاسلامي السيد حسين ابراهيم طه وزير الحج
والعمره الدكتور توفيق الربيعه في مقر
الامانه العامه اعقد الربيعه اثناء زيارته
الامانه العامه لقاء مع مندوبي وممثلي
وقناصل الدول الاعضاء في المنظمه واجهزتها
المتفرعه واكد ان المملكه منذ تاسيسها
تشرفت بخدمه الحرمين الشريفين
واصبحت قيمه راسخه تحظى بالاهتمام المباشر
من قبل الحكومه السعوديه التي جعلت من
خدمه ضيوف الرحمن منهجا تاريخيا حظيا
بارشاده كافه من دول العالم
مثمر
وتحدثنا عن فرص التعاون وفرص تطوير
الخدمات لضيوف الرحمن سواء للحجاج او
المعتمرين وكذلك ذكرنا التسهيلات تقدم
المملكه وكذلك الخطر التي قمت تقوم بها
المملكه لتقديم تسيير افضل وتسهل الوصول
جميع ضيوف الرحمن من جميع انحاء العالم
والذين خطه للتعامل مع المنظمه لبحث كل
سبل وعطر التعاون ممكنه لتقديم كل
التسهيلات
من صلاه الحجاج في مطار الملك عبد العزيز
بجده ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه نصفين هاني
مرحبا بك
الان كيف يبدو لك العمل الان في صاله
استقبال الحجاج ومن الخطه التشغيليه
الاستقبال الاعداد المليونيه ايضا
نعم اهلا بك خالد واهلا بمشاهدي قناه
العربيه قبل ان نبدا في حديثنا كاميرا
العربيه هنا في صاله الحجاج احد اكبر
الصلاه في مطار الملك عبد العزيز وتحديدا
في هذا الموسم وفي هذا الوقت نحن نتحدث عن
استقبال او لحظات استقبال الحجاج من مختلف
انحاء العالم طبعا نتحدث عن منصات لانهاء
الاجراءات نتحدث عن ايدي وكوادر البشريه
درب التدريبا جيدا نتحدث عن صلاه كبرى في
هذه تحديدا من خلال المطار او الصلاه
الحجاج والعمره وهي مقسمه الى اربعه عشر
صاله تستوعب هذه الصاله بيوميا من حيث
المغادره وايضا من حيث
القدوم اكثر من 100 الف مسافر هذه
التفاصيل جميعها سوف يكون ضيفي وهو
المتحدث الرسمي في المديريه عمل لجوازات
الرائد ناصر العتيبي مرحبا بك على شاشه
العربيه اليوم نتحدث عن تقنيات السعوديه
تسخرها من اجل انهاء اجراءات الحجاج كنا
في السابق نتحدث عن انهاء اجراءات الحاج
الواحد خلال دقيقه ونصف واليوم سمعت انه
خلال 40 ثانيه يتم انهاء هذه الاجراءات
للحج للحج الواحد ما هي هذه التقنيه
الجديده حياكم الله في جوازات مطار الملك
عبد العزيز تحديدا في صلاه الحج طبعا كما
ذكرت استمرارا للجهود التي تقدمها وزاره
الداخليه بدات المديريه العامه للجوازات
في تنفيذ خطتها لموسم الحج هذا العام 1444
والتي تتضمن من خلال جميع المنافذ الدوليه
سواء البريه او البحريه او الجويه ايضا
تتضمن استقبال حجاج بيت الله الحرام
وانهاء اجراءاتهم بعد التاكد من سلامه
الوثائق الخاصه بهم عملت المديريه العامه
للجوازات على تجويد خدماتها بما يضمن
[موسيقى]
التي تستقبل حجاج بالفوادر البشريه وايضا
بالاجهزه التقنيه الحديثه وايضا بالزملاء
والزميلات للذين يتحدثون العديد من اللغات
وبالاجاده التامه من خلال التواصل مع
الحجاج داخل صلاتهم
واستقبالهم والتخاطب معهم باللغات التي
يتحدثون بها مما يسهل على موظف الجوازات
سهوله التواصل مع المنسوب القادمين وايضا
يعطي انطباع وارتياح لي القادم لاداء
فريضه الحج عندما يجد مواطن سعودي يتحدث
معه بلهجته او بلغته فهو يعطي انتماء
انطباع وارتياح بكل تاكيد شكرا لك المتحدث
باسم المدير عام للجوازات الرائد ناصر
العتيبي اذن صلاه الحج والعمره هنا في
مطار الملك عبد العزيز وتحديدا في جده غرب
السعوديه نتحدث عن منصات لانهاء اجراءات
الحجاج تتجاوز 220 منصه نتحدث عن صلاه
مساحتها تتجاوز ال 500 الف متر مربع هنا
وصلته وعدد من حجاج القادمة من الهند
وكذلك في الجهه الاخرى القادمين من سوريا
وايضا هناك جنسيات اخرى وايضا رحلات اخرى
تستقبلها هذه الصاله التي بامكانها ان
تستوعب اكثر من 300 رحله في اليوم الواحد
لانهاء اجراء حجاج وصولهم بامن وسلام من
صاله الحجج في مطار الملك عبد العزيز في
جده شكرا جزيلا لك نصفي
نبقى ايضا في اخبار الحج حيث يستعد حوالي
35 الف مغربي للتوجه الى السعوديه من اجل
اداء فريضه الحج هذا العام كاميرا العربيه
رصدت من الرباط استعدادات بعض الحجاج
لرحله العمر
في منزلها في العاصمه الرباط تضع السيده
سهيله الترتيبات الاخيره على اغراضها وما
ستكون في حاجه اليه قبل موعد الرحله من
مطار الملك محمد الخامس في مدينه الدار
البيضاء
تقرب الى الله لان باش كتقرب على الله
كتكون الهديه دياله هو شنو اللي كيكون
الوالدين في الدنيا
هي صدقه جاريه
اولا ابن برك يدعو لك يقترب السيد احمد
البوعشراوي من عقده الثامن انتظر 14 عاما
للحصول على فرصه لاداء فريضه الحج ولم
يفقد الامل
الناس
التيسير وجاب الله الحمد لله ونشكره انا
فرحان الى اقصى درجه ماشي
فرحان
ان يتوجع حوالي 34 الفا من المغاربه من
ضيوف الرحمن عبر سبع مطارات مغربيه في
اتجاه السعوديه لاداء فريضه الحج عادل
الزبير العربيه الرباط
رابع بعد قليل السعوديه تحقق نموا كبيرا
في النقل الجوي وتحتل المرتبه الثالثه عشر
عالميا في مؤشر الربط الجوي
[موسيقى]
استنفار في بريطانيا ثلاثه حوادث امنيه
مترابطه في نوتينغام والعثور على ثلاثه
قتله واعتقال شخص
زخم سياسي واقتصادي تشهده السعوديه شهور
الخليل والاعلان عن طريق حرير جديد مع
الصين
وحجج السعوديه يبداون التوافد في
بورتسودان 747 حاجا سيتم تفويجهم
في السعوديه تكمل عامها الثاني ناقل جديد
وخصخصه مستمره للمطارات
قال الجمعيه العمل الامم المتحده تعتمد
العاشره من فبراير يوما عالميا للنمر
العربي
اهلا بكم من جديد وصل الرئيس الامريكي
السابق
لمواجهه اتهامات الجنائيه اتحاديه امام
المحكمه الفيدراليه بتهم الاحتفاظ بشكل
غير قانوني بوثائق تتعلق بالامن القومي
بعد مغادرته البيت الابيض عام 2021 من
المقرر ان يمثل ترامب امام المحكمه اليوم
الثالثه مساء بتوقيت شرق الولايات المتحده
حسين الطود مراسل العربيه ينضم الينا من
امام المحكمه الفيدراليه في ميامي اهلا
حسين ما الذي ننتظره هذا اليوم
اهلا بك خالد
وتحياتي لك انا الان موجود امام المحكمه
الفدراليه التي سيمثل فيها
بعد نحو خمس ساعات ونصف من الان على
الساعه الثالثه بتوقيت ميامي هذه المحكمه
كما قلنا هي في ميامي جنوب ولايه فلوريدا
طبعا هناك حضور اذا كنت ترى الصوره خلفي
هناك حضور اعلامي مكثف اضافه ايضا الى
حضور امني ولكن هو يختلف هذه المره عن ما
شاهدناه في نيويورك قبل تقريبا نحو شهرين
لا توجد حواجز حديديه على سبيل المثال فقط
اكتفت الشرطه بوضع خطوط من البلاستيك لعلم
العبور محيط المحكمه يمكن للمواطنين على
الاقتراب من على عكس ما كان في نيويورك
طبعا هناك ايضا حضور اكبر لمناصريه
فلوريدا هي ولايه جمهوريه اكثر عفوا لحضور
طبعا اكثر من منتقديه كما كان الحال في
نيويورك على الساعه الثالثه
تقريبا نفس السيناريو الذي حدث في نيويورك
قد يحدث لنا عليه التهم سيقول انه هو غير
مذنب وسيتم الافراج عنه بعد ذلك ليغادر
ويعود الى نيوجيرسي حيث من المتوقع ان
يلقي خطابا بعد الساعات من ذلك اذا انتهت
انتهاء الوصول على الساعه الثالثه والنصف
او الرابعه سيعود الى ان يجزي وهناك سيلقي
خطاب لمناصريه بالنسبه له وبالنسبه
لمؤيديه هو بريء هذه محاكمه سياسيه
تقوم بها اداره الرئيس بايدن لان الرئيس
بايدن كما يقول ترامب متخلف عنه بنسبه
بالاستطلاعات استطلاعات الراي حتى تناول
ذلك يخشى يخشى منه هذا ما يقوله ترامب
وهذا ما يريده به عدد من الجمهوريه كان
لافتا خالد خلال الايام الماضيه ان هناك
قسم من الجمهوريين خاصه في مجلس الشيوخ
ونتكلم على مستوى
القاده مثل الولائي به
جونسون وحتى جون كورنر وهؤلاء سيناتور
بارزين في مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي هم لم
يدافعوا عن ترامب والاوضحوا بانها
العداله يجب ان تسود على الجميع
المحاكمه كانت بالتاكيد يعني وما زالت مثل
الامن القومي الامريكي السابق ووزير عادل
كذلك سابق قال ان
الاتهامات الموجهه للرئيس الامريكي السابق
مدمره
انها يعني بمثابه تسديده جيده من بندقيه
وسيكون او قد تكون النهايه لمسيله مسيره
دونالد ترامب السياسيه
مدى يقول الاعلام الامريكي يعني حول هذه
القضيه مستقبل ترامب السياسي
والانتخابات بشكل عام
هناك اكثر من رايي على المستوى السياسي
هناك من يقول العكس خالد يقول ان هذه
المحاكمه زادت من نسبه تاييده خاصه لدى
القاعده الجمهوريه التي لم تستطع حتى الان
وقف الكثيرين من الابتعاد عن ارادته وما
يدل على ذلك هذا
التاييد له الكبير من قبل رؤساء مجلس
النواب والعديد من النواب الامريكيين في
المجلس النواب وايضا بالنسبه للمرشحين
المرشحين المحتملين ليقفوا ضده للحصول على
الترشيح من الحزب الجمهوري حتى اكثر
المرشحين
نعم
حتى من قبل اشد المنافسين لهم مثل راندا
الذي دافع عنه عدد من المرشحين من الحزب
الجمهوري يدافعون عنه باستثناء
وايضا
هناك اشخاص اخرين من المرشحين رفضوا دفاع
عنه وطالبوا بان يتم تتم محاسبته معظم
انا هنا هناك مشكله في الصوت لا اسمعك
جيدا لكن على كل حال على كل حال اعتذر منك
بالتاكيد سنتابع معك في نشراتنا اللاحقه
شكرا جزيلا لك حسين مراسل العربيه من امام
المحكمه الفيدراليه في ميامي
حققت السعوديه اعلى نمو في الربط الجوي
الدولي لقطاع الطيران في العالم وفقا لاخر
تقريبا صادر عن ايات تقدمت المملكه اربعه
عشره مرتبه لتصل الى المركز الثالث عشر
عالميا مقارنه بالمركز السابع والعشرين في
عام 2019 في مؤشر الربط الجوي الصادر عن
اتحاد النقل الجوي الدولي
المزيد عن استراتيجيات النقل السعوديه مع
شهد المتروك
ايام قليله وتكمل استراتيجيه السعوديه
للنقل والخدمات اللوجستيه عامها الثاني
بعد اطلاقها في الثلاثين من يونيو 20 واحد
وعشرين اطلاق ناقل جديد كان من ابرز اهداف
الاستراتيجيه وقد تحقق باطلاق طيران
الرياض الذي سيبدا نشاطه التجاري في العام
تستهدف الاستراتيجيه الى التوسع في
الوجهات الى
250 وجهه عالميه هذا التوسع يعني خصخصه
المطارات وهو ما حدث ويحدث في 25 مطارا في
جميع المناطق من خلال الشركات القابضه
التي تتولى تشغيلها
مليون مسافر سنويا رقم تريد السعوديه
تحقيقه بحلول العام 20 30
وسط تسارع لانجاز المشروع الاضخم في قطاع
النقل الجوي مطار الملك سلمان الذي وصفه
وزير النقل السعودي بانه سيمثل ثوره في
عالم المطارات الامير محمد بن سلمان قال
ان استراتيجيه النقل والخدمات اللوجستيه
ستمكن السعوديه من استغلال موقعها
الجغرافي وتعزيز القدرات البشريه والفنيه
في القطاع
اعتمدت الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
اليوم بالاجماع القرار المعنون اليوم
العالمي للنمر العربيه الذي قدمته المملكه
وشارك في رعايته اكثر من 30 دوله حدد
القرار الذي قدمه مندوب المملكه الدائم
لدى الامم المتحده
السفير عبد العزيز الواصل يوم العاشر من
فبراير يوم العالميا للنمر العربي حيث يتم
الاحتفال به سنويا يصلي القرار الضوء على
النمر العربي كونه احد اكثر انواع النمور
المهدده بالانقراض ويؤكد على اهميته
لحمايه الحياه البريه والتنوع البيولوجي
من العلا ينضم الينا رئيس قطاع التواصل
والعلاقات العامه في الهيئه الملكيه
لمحافظه العلي عبد الرحمن عبد الرحمن حياك
الله معي عشره فبراير اذا هو اليوم
العالمي للنمر العربي حسب الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده كيف تم الوصول لهذه النتيجه
طبعا اول شيء
نتقدمئه ولي العهد
لانه الاهتمام بكل الملفات البيئيه وعلى
راسها النمر العربي اللي هو اعلى
المستهدفه المفترسات في الجزيره العربيه
كانوا من البدايه كان في عده خطوات
الحقيقه على مستوى البيئي وعلى المستوى
ايضا اللوجستي ورفع الوعي بالنمر العربي
اللي ابدا بمساله الوعي كان في عده
مبادرات وفي تعاون مع عده منظمات منها
الاتحاد والحفاظ على البيئه وبانثيرا
ومؤسسه كاتبوسفير التي تراسها سمو سفيره
خادم الحرمين في واشنطن ثم اتى ايضا دعم
اضافي من الحكومه في بدايه العام المنصرم
عبر تحديد 10 فبراير كيل كيوم للنمر
العربي
واحتفلنا فيه في العام الماضي في هذا
العام واليوم تاتي هذه الخطوه الحقيقه
تتويجا حيث يكون يوما عالميا يرفع وعيه
على مستوى
ومن اهم الكائنات الحيه في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والجزيره العربيه بشكل
كامل
وما هي الطبيعه الجهود التي قامت بها
الهيئه الملكيه محافظه العلا للمحافظه على
بيئه النمر العربي في المملكه
النمر العربي بالنسبه لنا هو هو دره التاج
عندما ان شاء الله يعاد اطلاق اوفياء
المحميات
في العلماء كان هناك عده خطوات لاعاده
النظم البيئيه اولا حدد اكثر من نصف مساحه
محافظه العلا لتكون خمس محميات طبيعيه ما
يزيد على 12 الف كيلو متر من ضمن حوالي
22,000 وهي مساحه محافظه العلا وهي محميه
شرعان بالاضافه الى اربع محميات ثم اصبح
هناك الحفاظه الحقيقه على النباتات
الموجوده النباتات الاصيله وكان عندنا
ايضا حمله تشجير
حققت 120 الف نبته منذ العام 2019
ولديها حق نسبه بقاء مرتفعه مقارنه
بالمعدلات العالميه وهي 89% نسبه ما يبقى
من هذه الاشجار ثم بالاضافه الى ذلك
وبالتعاون مع الحياه الفطريه وعده مؤسسات
في المملكه وفي دول الخليج تم اطلاق عده
عده حيوانات وكان اول اطلاق من لندن سمو
سيدي في فبراير 2019 يعني جنبك نمر كمان
عربي عبد الرحمن ولا
مهتم انت فيها شخصيه ان النمر العربي
الملكيه لمحافظه العلا
خلال هذه الايام تتعامد امس تتعامد الشمس
على البحر الاحمر ما يؤدي لهبوب رياح
مثيره للغبار على سواحل السعوديه واليمن
تفاصيل دائما مع خالد الزعل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وموسم الغبيره يؤثر على الليث والقنفذ هو
جازان والسواحل التهاميه وكذلك حجه
والحديده باليمن يبدا نشاطها من المنقلبه
الصيفي ب 22 يونيو ويمتد الى دخول موسم
سهيل وسهيل كوجنه الحب في اللون وقلب
المحب
في الخفقان
[موسيقى]
في بريطانيا ثلاثه حوادث مترابطه في
العثور على ثلاثه قتلو واعتقال شخص
زخم سياسيا واقتصادي تشهده السعوديه الشهر
الحالي والاعلان عن طريق حرير جديد
حجاج السوداني يبداون التوافد في بورسودان
747 حاجا سيتم تفويجهم الى جده
واستراتيجيه الناقل في السعوديه تكمن
عامها الثاني ناقل جديد وخسخه مستمره
للمطارات
والعاشر من فبراير يوم عالمي للنمر العربي
حسب الجمعيات العامه للامم المتحده
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات